have you had bad auditions no I mean
like where
um you really are embarrassed
yeah yeah I remember
um
what happened
you gotta tell us
you gotta tell a story
it's a little wiggle I thought
it ended when you know like you're
crying I didn't know if she was actually
crying or laughing glad that the scene
ended when you know both the characters
stopped talking but it turns they go
energy gets shot I was like excuse me
then she gets shot and you didn't know
that you didn't read the sides so I did
I said thing I was gonna have to do it
it was stupid
it looks such an idiot I was like
just like oh you just did a little thing
like that no like I committed to it but
like after talking about it
I feel like I hit the wall a little bit
with my shoulder wiggle
and I just remember thinking my brain my
actual real-time thought was I just wish
they weren't filming this because then
only three of us would know this
happened we'd be down to three people
were you laughing about this during the
moment or are you just so embarrassed
afterwards
after like now it's hilarious because
that was like 20 years ago did you get
the part no I did not get the part
oh my God I think I've had those what
happened to you well I had a moment with
um
uh the guy who directed Beavis and
Butthead Mike Mike Judge
obviously a lot of actors have said oh
my God I love Beavis I love Mike Jones
he's a genius
and I went in for this audition and I go
he likes weird he likes off the you know
just out there okay
and I came in I wore a wig I think
because because you were like keeping it
tight at that time I wasn't Lex Luthor
then okay
but I wore this wig
and this
checkered shirt
and a gold chain
and I had a little toy
a little ceramic Golden Retriever
dogs I have a lot of questions I don't
know and I went up
and I just put the golden retriever on
the desk
and then I angled it to him to look at
him and he was like okay
and then I just started doing the scene
and it was weird and I took these really
strange beats and I was kind of doing a
little accent man
[__] that man
doing something really out there and I
thought man he's gonna go and he goes
okay thank you very much thanks thanks
so much thanks and then you just gotta
pick up the golden retriever and then I
clicked the golden retriever
then I walked out and I go
I don't know I I might have done
something really well there I don't I
don't know I don't maybe he's just
because you look like my manager called
me and said what did you do in there
you're welcome did I get it and I go it
goes dude Mike Judge says he's never
been more freaked out than audition
than the moment when you walked in and
gave that reading that's pretty cool
it wasn't good
it was not good